[موسيقى]
PJI
هي شركة طائرات بدون طيار تصنع أيضًا
كاميرات هذه الأيام. GoPro هي شركة كاميرات ،
لكنها أيضًا تصنع طائرات
بدون طيار ، سنختار أعين الدي جي أحدثها أرخص وأصغر طائرة بدون طيار هذا الجزء ضد GoPros بدون طيار Karma ونحن
سنستخدمهم لالتقاط كل
حركة الباركور ، هذه الحديقة صغيرة جدًا
لدرجة أنها يمكن أن تقلع مباشرة من
يدك بينما أتعلم قفزتي الأولى
، الشرارة هي التسجيل على كاميرا عالية الدقة
لا تحتوي على  دقة 4K
لـ GoPro ولكنني اضطررت
لتقليص حجم بعض الميزات لتلائم
هذه الطائرة الصغيرة بدون طيار على الرغم من أن
اللقطات تبدو جيدة جدًا حيث
تلتقط الطائرة بدون طيار كل الأحداث عندما
يتحول شخص ما يقودها إلى
ميزة التتبع التلقائي للشرر  يتبعني
عندما أتحرك ببطء ولكن عندما
تلتقط سرعة الباركور تأخر الطائرة بدون طيار هذا ،
نعم أحب بعضًا حسنًا ، يمكنك الآن أيضًا
التحكم في الشرارة بإيماءات اليد إذا كان
بإمكانك حفظها جميعًا لالتقاط صورة سيلفي
بعيدة عن متناول ذراعك.
تبلغ تكلفة الطائرة بدون طيار الصغيرة الخاصة بعيون DJ بإصبعك 500
دولارًا ، أما GoPros Karma فإن حافة
GoPros فوق الشرارة هي محورها ثلاثي الاتجاهات الذي يعمل على
تثبيت الكاميرا ، لذلك عندما تصبح الرحلات الجوية
قاسية ، لا يجب أن يتغير الفيديو ،
لا تحتوي الكرمة على التتبع أو
الإيماءة  تحكم في الشرارة ولكن ما
فعلته GoPro حقًا هنا هو بناء
طائرة بدون طيار حول كاميرتها ، حيث
يمنحك سعرها الكبير الكاميرا بدون طيار وجهاز تحكم عن بعد
بالإضافة إلى عصا سيلفي عالية التقنية
حيث تقصر جميع الطائرات بدون طيار هو
عمر
البطارية أكثر منك  يمكن الخروج من الكرمة
20 دقيقة ، الشرارة 16 فقط
جيدًا ، لا يمكنك تعلم الباركور في يوم واحد فقط
ولكن يمكنك التعرف على هاتين الطائرتين
بدون طيار جيدًا على الرغم من
الاضطرابات التي ضربتها GoPros karma عندما
خرجت لأول مرة  كان لديك استدعاء كبير الآن
إذا كنت متحمسًا للذهاب إلى ، يمكنك استخدام
هذه الكاميرا الصغيرة كلها من تلقاء نفسها ، يمكنك وضعها
على عصي الاستقرار الذاتي أو
استخدامها فقط على هذه الطائرة بدون طيار دون الحاجة إلى
القلق بشأن الانهيار من السماء ولكن
شرارة DJI تخفض الشريط  حواجز
للناس لشراء أول طائرة بدون طيار ،
يكون حجمها صغيرًا وسعرها أقل تكلفة
، وإذا كانت الميزات الآلية
ستغري على الأرجح موجة جديدة كاملة من الطيارين
للإقلاع